[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur un autre chantier
écologique à la possession
je m'appelle jean charles verte j'ai 41
ans et je viens vous présenter
écologique qui a été créée en avril 2020
moi j'ai toujours fait des chantiers
j'étais directeur travaux dans chez
bouygues dans un groupe associé dans un
gros cabinet archi est
une démarche personnelle j'ai fait ma
maison et elle est sortie rapidement pas
cher et écologique et donc ensuite on a
pensé à le faire pour les autres mais
plus grosse aide ça a vraiment été à la
technopole puisqu'ils m'ont incuber et
bpi dans le cas d'une bourse fin de
chaque pluie qu'on fait de l'innovation
en fait il fallait financer à
l'innovation est le prototype que je
vais vous présenter
à nos construit des bâtiments
écologiques durables à accous aider les
maîtriser on fait de l'éco conception
donc on est connu pour nos bâtiments
containers parce qu'on laissait les
seuls à faire aux normes ils sont 50%
moins cher
quatre à douze fois plus rapide et 80%
plus écolo mais on fait tout type de
bâtiment
l'idée c'est de trouver la meilleure
solution par rapport à votre projet
souvent c'est votre terrain votre budget
et vous quand vous mais avec un projet
en fait on fait un art ont permis de
construire on regarde quels seraient les
meilleures solutions et après on va
jusqu'à la réalisation clés en main donc
les étapes c'est faisabilité permet de
construire
un plan exe et suivi travaux
aujourd'hui justement quand vous propose
vous venez avec un projet soit le
constructeur soit l'archi va vous dire
mais c'est comme ça qu'on fait une
maison shakarchi à est limité en fait
par son expérience par sa vision et
l'idée c'est qu'en fait vous vous
appropriez votre projet l'innovation à
consiste en une plateforme qui vous
permet de concevoir de faire des
différents choix de regarder différents
scénarios pour votre maison donc d'abord
par exemple la structure est ce que vous
une structure en bois en maçonnerie en
containers en connaissant les prix et
les impacts environnementaux
l'étape d'après vous ferez votre bardage
l'enveloppent autour l'étape d'après ces
voitures est ce qu'on met de la lui est
ce qu'on met du photovoltaïque est ce
qu'on met de la toiture végétale vous
allez justement pouvoir regarder toutes
les alternatives possibles
en sachant exactement où est ce que ça
vous mène et à la fin vous ferez votre
choix qui est le vôtre en fait en
fonction de votre budget en fonction de
vos goûts et en fonction de votre façon
de vivre le proverbe qui correspondrait
bien en projet c'est savais pas que
c'était impossible à la rue en fête